méthode répété à grande échelle et aux
effets dévastateurs
ce sont les conclusions d'une nouvelle
enquête menée sur le terrain par
amnistie internationale sur les
agissements russes dans le nord ouest de
kiev l'organisation assure que des
dizaines de crimes de guerre ont été
commis dans cette région oui non date
prime comité de nous savons que les
crimes commis contre les personnes
vivant autour de kiev dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui ne sont pas simplement
anecdotique ou accessoires ou
collatéraux
nous savons qu'ils font parti d'un
modèle qui a caractérisé la conduite des
hostilités
mené par la russie depuis le début lo ng
a rassemblé les témoignages de 45
personnes dont les proches ont été
victimes d'homicides illégaux selon le
droit de la guerre ce terme désigne les
meurtres de civils par des forces
militaires des exactions commises à bord
elle boude chat ou encore borodianka
abordé en cas des frappes aériennes ont
tué au moins 40 civils dans des attaques
aveugles et disproportionnées
abuja et aux alentours vingt-deux cas
d'homicides illégaux commis par les
forces russes ont été répertoriés la
plupart étaient des exécutions
extrajudiciaires manifeste des
exécutions extrajudiciaires constitutifs
de crimes de guerre au regard du droit
international
lo ng milite désormais pour que les
auteurs soient jugés et reconnu
pénalement responsable qu'ils soient
simples militaires haut gradés de leur
côté les autorités ukrainiennes assure
que 9000 crimes de guerre pourraient
avoir été commis sur tout le territoire
la russie elle dément ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'elle est accusé de
crimes de guerre en ukraine ou dans le
conflit en syrie